so eli morgan making his 12th start he's
two and five on the on the year
then he hammers this ball hard out to
right center that one goes over the head
of straw up against the wall connor
falefa into third base and they will
stop him there on the garcia double
here's low with the infield back
oh that ball
struck well
deep out there to center and gone
[Applause]
a three-round homer for nathaniel lowe
and a free baseball for that dude diving
over the seats
something about nathaniel lowe when he
has ducks on the pond and those runners
out there in scoring position
he crushes baseballs
and this one is a no doubter
nice early and easy timing
look at that that ball's about
12 15 rows deep look at that change up
grip
the season numbers for taylor hearn
adding another start tonight
ramirez can run he's not going anywhere
and there's a swing and a miss at the
fastball 96 miles per hour and heard
with a couple of strikeouts in his
scoreless first inning lead off man
aboard for dj peters who flies deep
right his first time up
there's a hard hit ball ramirez flags it
down gets one ernie's turn is in time
a double play five four three around the
horn they go
well you're gonna be ready uh on the
field tonight boy these guys are they're
raking and this is jose steals a hit
away and turns it into a double flight
great defense
valent turns it and i thought that ball
was buying but boy oh boy he reached all
the way out goes right into the glove
they turn too
left-handed hitting right fielder daniel
johnson the only lefty in the lineup
as johnson liftoff jet leaves the yard
big blast overall number four indians
get on the board here at inning number
three
now a four-game hitting streak he's gone
six for his last 12. that's how you earn
more playing time
he put a good swing on it rosetta
breaking ball down
short
very short yeah yes he did daniel just
smoked that ball nathaniel excuse me
coming up
morgan
a quick visit and low
smashes that ball deep center field and
that one is off the fence
into third base
is garcia and low
with a double is three for three and
he's a triple shy of the cycle now up
there with a chance to cash in a couple
and that one got him
and then he got him looked like on the
wrist or the hand
and so the bases are loaded
i think demarlo hale wants to
to look at this one
we'll see here take another look
i feel like that's pretty distinctive
yeah that's about it that's that's even
the bottom of the knob and you even see
some distance
[Applause]
they've been successful nine times on 12
challenges
bouncer shortstop that'll get a run to
the plate
and rosario goes out peters for the
second out of the inning rbi ground out
the two two
three him out with a fast ball that was
pinpoint low-key
but the rangers tack one on they lead it
4-1
chang bounced into a double play his
first time up in the second inning
fly ball and deep center back is tavares
he's out of room it's out of here you
chang with home run number four on the
year
and the indians cut the gap to 4-2 did a
nice job
going out and getting that run back on
one swing watch it that's another slider
both sliders have been hit out of the
ballpark
won by johnson this one by chang so they
get that lead back and now he's trying
to get through this fifth for only the
second time jose ramirez has walked and
struck y'all
jose bloops one right center that's
gonna drop and get down rosario with a
great jump he's digging for third he'll
get there safely nobody home at second
and ramirez moves up to the open base
and now the indians are in business with
a beautiful piece of hitting by ramirez
some aggressive base running by rosario
and more intelligent base running by
ramirez
down two
and they've got two in scoring position
with nobody out
there's a high fly ball center field
deep enough to get a run home ahmed
rosario tags
jose ramirez tags and takes a look
the run comes home rosario scores it's a
one-run game now at four to three give
rodman reyes rbi number 61.
going both ways this one hit hard out to
left field but that's going to stay in
the yard peters is there
and the inning is done the indians get
another run back
four to three texas two down seventh
inning
mile straw in a dead sprint doesn't what
a catch holy smokes
completely extended
miles straw racing to the track and
right center
laid out to make the diving catch
[Applause]
he's got some stuff to straighten out in
the seventh inning chang at second
johnson at first
oh man popped it up
and that is out number
one there's a line drive and throw back
to second
double play
not the ground ball double play
but the line out throw out double play
had a
scoreless outing
in boston four days ago
all right 2-2 from cotton
and he got him looking
reyes turned back
at a 1-2-3 inning for jarrell cotton
brings up low on a four for four night
bouncer left side that's a fair ball
back of the bag and ramirez has no play
it's a five-hit game for nathaniel lowe
with two men on and two outs better is
dj peters
all right another 3-2
and this one in the air out to right
field johnson was in shallow it's gone
dj peters with a three-run blast in the
ninth and he's he'll open it up for the
rangers
peters
finally took advantage it really seemed
like it was a matter of time it was it
was really about the location of the
pitch
peters chased up in the zone a little
bit but he saw the same pitch to say it
was nine or ten pitches either way it
was a great at bat nine pitches all
cutters was able to see it enough to
make an adjustment bottom of the ninth
inning
and the chance to put this one away as
brett mark checks in
one two
and he chops it towards second high hop
for solac ball game well you got the
right pitch anyway
that'll do it a one two three for martin